-Well, guys,
it's the last day of October,
so I thought it'd be nice
to give a little recap
of the entire month.
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ October is over, so ♪
♪ Ten months down
and two to go ♪
♪ We're all focused
on one person ♪
♪ She made... ♪
-"1989 (Taylor's Version)"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Congress couldn't
find a speaker ♪
♪ Our country
was down a leader ♪
♪ Tempers, they began to flare
like ♪
-Subject to the call
of the chair.
[ Gavel bangs loudly ]
[ Laughter ]
-♪ "Golden Bachelor" is great ♪
♪ Love to watch him
go on dates ♪
♪ But the women
sometimes fight ♪
♪ And Gary
cannot drive at night ♪
[ Truck horn honks ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ We saw "Saw" and "Exorcist" ♪
♪ "Five Nights at Freddy's"
was legit ♪
♪ There was so much stuff
to scare us ♪
♪ But not as bad as... ♪
-A bedbug infestation in Paris.
-♪ Trump spent every day
in court ♪
♪ Mike Pence
cut his campaign short ♪
♪ The whole thing
was kind of strange ♪
♪ Just like ♪
-"The Star Spangled Banner,"
performed tonight
by Flavor Flav.
[ Laughter ]
-♪ iPhone 15 overheats ♪
♪ Keeps you warm
for trick-or-treat ♪
♪ We dress up for Halloween ♪
♪ I'll go as ♪
-The Kevin James meme.
[ Laughter ]
-♪ Another month
has come and gone ♪
♪ Leaves are falling
on your lawn ♪
♪ November will be better,
surely ♪
♪ Unless you are
a freakin' turkey ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'll play this one day.